so many streamers have those like intro
videos i don't have anything like that
so i'm always like it's a wild guess
did it work i'm not sure
um it looks like it worked
success i have to wait for an ad to play
first
all right we did it cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone um today
we're gonna be talking about one
division full spoilers so if you haven't
seen the show please stop watching
um this will be sort of a spoiler cast
but less structured just uh got some
friends together to give opinions
on the things so hi i'm alana that is
andrew goldberg who works for sucker
punch that is paris lily
games personality you seem on kind of
funny and gamertag radio and that
is writer and actress danny fernandez
welcome friends
how do we feel about the show
i don't never know where to start but i
guess like what i what i like to ask
first with this kind of thing is um
anyone have any strong opinions on on
anything major that happened feel free
to just
go right for it how do we like it
i loved it personally um i thought it
did a great job
of telling a self-contained story
about wanda dealing with her grief
and also an origin story for her
becoming the scarlet witch
um so in that sense i thought it did a
fantastic job
now i also have a strong opinion that
they did
a horrible job with the trolling they
over trolled us
in this series because there were so
many easter eggs that hinted at so many
different things
that just simply didn't go anywhere and
obviously the pietro one is the biggest
of them all
speculating for weeks it was just such a
weird choice
but i feel like that i feel like it's a
tongue-in-cheek thing though because
marvel's
known to do that so i don't know if i
agree
but i also think kovid really messed
them up yeah for sure
really messed them up and even adam
lavik
who's on heroes forge he just like
released a video where it looked like
uh elizabeth olsen had set like they had
to adr something he was like it doesn't
match up
with her mouth and i do think because
they weren't
like this wasn't originally supposed to
be the first one that dropped that a lot
of things got messed up no way i didn't
know that
especially because they had they had to
stop filming had to come back
and uh this i believe that this was not
the first
um i think winter soldier was yeah this
was like
fourth i think it was like yeah so so
i think paris some of those things are
gonna happen
i think that they're kind of be a little
bit out of order i understand it's
frustrating to be teased about something
and then not have it come true
but i do think some of it the pietro
thing i think was just a tongue
yeah yeah yeah like i don't think that
they actually meant for us to take it
the way
that everyone did it's also but that's
just my thoughts
yeah like it's made harder by all the
rumors about like there are gonna be
three spider-man and multiverse and blah
blah and i think like
that stuff built up expectations in a
way that um like kevin feige was talking
to tca a week or so ago
that they have to craft the films after
this for people who didn't necessarily
see these disney plus threes and i think
that's a really
like that'll create kind of this weird
split where there will be important
stuff in them like it's not like it's
going to be like you know
inconsequential
but i do wonder like it's probably not
the place we're gonna get
the x-men you know it's probably not
where reed richards is gonna come in
and so i think some of those um that
expectation setting just hadn't happened
yet because this is the first one
so maybe with falcon the winter soldier
it'll be a little clearer no yeah i i
agree with that danny you make you make
the fantastic point about that because
if i remember correctly the original
schedule was going to be black widow
we were going to get the eternals we
were going to get spider-man 3
and falcon in the winter soldier were
all happening before
juan division so and i could see where
potentially
the mutant gene gets introduced during
the eternals obviously the multiverse
stuff
if they're going to do the multi the
multiple spiderman and then that
all this stuff would culminate and pay
off obviously with the multiverse of
madness with doctor strange
but i think even regardless of that and
all that is completely valid
um yeah it worked
better if you just focus because i'll
just say this i'm sure we're going to
bounce around on stuff
i really reeled in all my expectations
after episode 8 because that's when it
clicked for me that
oh wait this is all about wanda this is
about
wanda and vision and grief this is not
about
mutants magneto's not about to walk
through that door none of this stuff is
happening
set expectations accordingly and i think
when i did that going into episode nine
i felt a lot better about it and then it
was just like the phrase i was like okay
they got me
i thought it was pretty pretty fantastic
so i think my take is it'll be
so different because i did not go into
this
as an mcu thing at all like i had
no interest in seeing any cameos i had
no interest in it building anything up
it got me so hard on the hook of like
this incredibly powerful woman dealing
with grief
and how it can affect everyone else
around her obviously we're seeing that
through the lens of a witch it can
affect people in dramatic ways but of
her like coming to terms with what's
happened to her
and letting her her grief like really
negatively impact an entire community
and her maybe not even realizing that's
happening because she's so overwhelmed
with grief and it's like
if you're you're grieving it can be
really destructive to all of your
relationships and i was like so into
that thread
that the minute that it was like here's
a villain here's another villain oh and
another villain i was like can we
could it just actually be about wanda
like i'm so
much further back that i was like i
don't need any mcu in this
like it can be there and that's cool but
i i had no expectations for like movies
going forward i feel like the
the the point where it introduced the
villains on top of that concept where i
wish that she had have just been the
villain of her own story
and realized how how that was affecting
her i was like that would have been so
much
more powerful but then it blew up into
this like thing that even i felt was too
big so then
the perspective like i remember paris
you were the one who tweeted uh
something along the lines of like set
your expectations know that this is a
story about wander and i saw your tweet
and i was like i hope so
like i wanted it to be even further back
than i was
because i feel like this weird middle
ground that it ended up in of like
having
like a couple of things you mentioned
like tiny easter eggs that set you in
the direction of it tying into the mcu
and then not a lot of them i would have
preferred absolutely none
like go hard or nothing and i recognize
that clover does put them in a really
weird
just timeline in terms of production of
like how much they can tease when you
don't even know when necessarily
movies can go back to full filming
schedules right now like it is a
really weird time to drop this but i
think that the stuff that i liked the
most was
like the whole build-up i loved all of
the just the set design and the costumes
and the different styles of acting
like in the first episodes i thought was
so so so cool and i was so into
that especially like like danny i
imagine that must been super interesting
for someone like you if i found it
interesting to be like how did they make
this like
making sure that every shot is that way
and all the writing is even
consistent with those ears was so cool
i was just talking to hector navarro
about this and
um i was like a lot of us would love to
be able to take these risks
but like aren't allowed to because of
stu like because of studios and notes
and
it's the same thing with like flea bag
i'm like a lot of us want to break the
fourth wall a lot of us want to be able
to do these things and
when you're marvel you get to do that so
i think that's really cool that they
successfully had
an episode in each decade and and i hope
that more
studios will allow the rest of us to
take a lot of risks when we're making
things
um i feel like into the spider-verse was
one of the reasons it was so
successful is because we hadn't seen
anything like it there was so many risks
that they took they like just
allowed them to play and i love when
creatives and show runners and show
creators get to just play
so that's what i enjoyed a lot about
this and i hope that they honestly i
hope they do that with their other shows
too i know she hulk
is doing that uh i think she breaks the
fourth wall a lot in that and i just
i i mean i don't like formulaic things
so like just
i i just like getting to to take a lot
of risks and
not all of us get to do that but it was
it was so creative and just like
like as someone who did you know grow up
watching really old shows and watching
the witched and all that stuff i'm sure
a lot of people did i was like so happy
when i saw people tweeting complaints
about it being too slow i was like
i love this like i am so cool with all
of this the minute you ramped the
villains up was when i was like we just
throw it back a bit
but i imagine that is probably a studio
thing that they had to do i can picture
that being
a script that was adapted from this that
is just about wanda and just about her
grief but then
you know to be marvel they're like let's
build it up a little bit more let's
let's increase this they they have to
tie it into the bigger picture
exactly like the blessing occurs yeah
it's like i think that's where the mcu
is like incredible and everything
something and it's all this like
interconnected stuff and it's part of a
larger hole but also yeah
it like kind of also needs to work in a
vacuum and on its own and i think the
the best or at least my favorite mcu
things
tend to like i really think like i can
watch for ragnarok
without really thinking too hard about
like how it's going to tie you know the
infinity war got set up in it and
everything else like um but i do think
like with all the villain stuff it it
feels like a larger problem
with pretty much all superhero stuff
recently i mean i think like even the
ones like thor ragnarok or even like
non-mcu stuff like logan or if you look
at end game and all these things like
it really is always eventually a a bunch
of cool cgi powers and explosions and
people running at each other and
i feel like there's sort of this like
the world ending stakes is what gets me
it's like what if we didn't have to end
the entire world with this one
could we just dial it back i also felt
like some of the cg was actually kind of
bad towards the end is was that just me
yeah it was yeah right yeah i agree it
was like a tv budget for sure like you
can tell that it's not you know you're
not watching
like you know the budget per episode was
i i assume like
a fifth or a tenth of of what uh you
know i'm sure the full season was a was
a movie scale budget but yeah like
spread across nine episodes i'm sure
that makes it
way harder but yeah and you won't bring
up the great point because i think
that's what made this
this series overall so good because it
wasn't relying on
vision flying through the sky and
phasing through things and wanda
destroying buildings
it was more about character development
was about
understanding who wanda is her past her
grief why she is the way that she is and
we even got to find out more about
vision in that way as well that he's
always
served the needs of others and then you
got to see him
slowly start to understand that this
world wasn't
right and the fact that wanda couldn't
control him
he was going off on his own he's being
gaslit who am i
what is this yeah yeah it was it was
really good really really but i also
feel like people used
to say that about the marvel tv shows
that it was too slow
they said that about luke cage and a lot
of those and i just feel like it's
because we're in a binge
culture yeah i don't agree with that
like i think there's a reason they
dropped it weekly you're supposed to
digest it enjoy it think about it i also
think it
is more memorable that way like it just
is
because it's like same with game of
thrones like you knew everybody was
watching it that weekend and
like all the memes were gonna come out
and they're really smart about that
uh studios are really smart when it
comes to pr and people tweeting about
their shows
but i just don't think that everything
should be digested so quickly i don't
think that all the superhero shows they
mean anything if it's just fighting and
and getting to the villain so quickly
like you just don't care about the
characters as much you have to be able
to sit with the characters
in their love in their romantic
relationships in their grief and that
like in their daily lives i mean that's
why i would always read fan fiction
growing up
fan fiction was always about the daily
life the slice of life for me at least
that you don't get to see when you're
doing those heavy hitting like end game
infinity war like you don't have time
necessarily to sit in those moments yeah
and i think the
the character development like that you
get out of a tv format is amazing
because if you
if you think of like pure screen time
like
this like whatever it was uh roughly
five hours or so in total
and like wanda's in 75 of those scenes i
imagine just in terms of raw screen time
she's probably up there with tony stark
and steve rogers
now that's weird to think about if you
think about wanda and vision
well and it's even weirder with wanda
and vision together because if you think
about like cap and peggy or even
tony and pepper like how much actual
screen time have we seen
compared to wand and vision is it crazy
you know if you go back to episode 8
again
and you watch that scene where they did
the flashback into civil war
and you you have the scene where wanda
and vision are
you know just sitting on the bed and to
me that is the most character
development we've had in the entire mcu
and
that oh my god you're seeing the exact
moment that they fell in love and then
obviously uh vision tells that
that really uh a really great line about
grief and you know love
but that that that to me was like the
best part of this entire series right
there and it didn't involve any special
effects or anything it was two
characters sitting in a room
just talking and you understood
everything that was going on you
understood
why wanda is doing what she's doing and
another thing with that i
during the course of the series which
danny you bring up the great point the
fact that
we couldn't binge it and have to watch
it week the week i was going back and
watching old mcu stuff so
if you go back and watch infinity war
and you watch the scene with wanden
vision in the hotel in scotland
it's heartbreaking it's heartbreaking
because he's telling her
what if i don't go back this time what
if i choose you i want
you i know i no longer want that let's
run away together
and then boom you know everything
happens obviously with infinity war
so it's tragic so then when you get to
that end scene with when thanos takes
the mind stone
oh like you understand wanda's grief
because for her if you look at the
timeline of this she immediately gets
snapped
and it's only been three weeks for her
when we get to one division
all that happened in a three-week period
for her so of course she's gonna
lose it and create a hex and try to make
her a reality
[Laughter]
um speaking of like the character
development bits of just like you know
seeing the two of them together the part
where they do the magic show
is probably one of my favorite scenes
and anything to do with the mcu
like i thought it was so creative to
have like this person who can in theory
manipulate even the laws of physics
and this pretend magician who is in fact
like a sentient robot
who's drunk like i thought that was
brilliant like i was so happy to see
that the way that they played that off
of each other was like this could only
exist in this franchise
and that her protecting him in that way
was just so so so cute and they were
like so many little bits like that that
i was like
this concept is so absurd that if you
described it to anyone who wasn't
familiar with these properties it would
be completely nonsensical but it worked
so well
and they had just loads of cute bits it
also somehow felt
yeah and they all felt weirdly period
appropriate like i think like
like just going back to how well it's
made like the way
the the humor how it worked in each of
those episodes like that did feel like a
weird slap sticky
you know uh 50 60 show style plot and i
feel like um
even just the scenarios involved in each
one it's so cool the way they really did
manage to make you feel authentic i
i but also have a sentient robot and
magic and all this stuff you know like
they really managed to like balance that
like surprisingly well how do you think
people have not watched those kinds of
shows
feel about it like if you've never seen
bewitched how do you think younger
audiences
would have felt about the first few
episodes would have just been oh i can i
can 100 tell you
my kids yeah they thought it was weird
and boring
like none of us were alive then i think
it's just that it ran on reruns like
before streaming services you know
like oh much of that show but you're
right it is before us as well
but i feel like yeah that's that's a
bummer but it doesn't surprise me so
then i wonder who the target audience is
it probably is more mature audiences
it's a mature even in the first episode
they you know
it's like the last two seconds obviously
but like the credits you do get that
thing at the very end of episode one
where it's like
eventually we know it's darcy but you
see someone watching so at least like
like because i was really impressed how
hard they committed yeah i was watching
that first night when they did the first
two but also i think those little
moments of like that like
two second break was obviously for
people who were a little
uh not impressed with the format or
waiting for something to happen
yeah so so did you also catch that
when we got again i keep going to
episode 8 for so much but
when we we go to sokovia where she's
young with the bomb
but you you get the scene with the
parents and they show all the vcr tapes
and it's obviously all the different
eras of tv but in a way that was
their hex in sokovia because that was
their little bubble inside their
apartment
where they got to escape the realities
of everything that was going on
outside in scovie i thought that was a
an interesting look i haven't thought of
that that's actually
that's very sweet yeah it's like her
using a coping mechanism that she had as
a kid for
the same thing when she's an adult
because that's like the age where you
would learn how to do that stuff is the
way your parents do it i guess like i
hadn't thought about that and
again i think it's a grief story it's so
so so strong and i just
my biggest takeaway seems like i feel so
weird to be like i just wish i had
nothing to do with the mcu why did you
have to do any of this like it was
such a good story um but i guess like to
go right into the mcu let's just like
jump in there uh what do we think white
vision means
spoilers i mean i i think that uh the
idea oh yeah this is all full spoilers
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i hope so
i'm not looking to chat everyone's
saying that uh yeah i mean i uh
like i'm i'm like obsessed with mcu but
way less obsessive comics so i don't
really know a ton about it um i don't
know if any of you guys know
more but so correct me if i'm wrong but
from what i understand just from
like reddit browsing they they'll
essentially go for the idea that like
this is vision
like in all but emotion basically so
like he now has those memories in him he
now
he has the physical form he has some
degree of understanding of the fact that
he
had this relationship etc etc but if he
runs into wanda
it's not like her vision you know like
it's not like they're gonna have
um that instant spark or whatever so
it's kind of this weird dynamic where
it actually could be pretty damn
heartbreaking when that moment happens
when
you know if vision is really back uh
in this weird new form that's like gotta
be pretty hard for her if they end up
coexisting so i think it's like it could
just be a really interesting
twist on that relationship yeah from the
comics and i'm
by no means any big expert you're pretty
correct on that
that white vision or spectral vision
symbolizes
he's literally just an android yes he
will have all his memories but he has no
emotion
he has no attachment to humanity he just
goes about his job and that's it so like
you're saying
i imagine somewhere down the road
obviously him and juan are going to
reunite
and what does that mean having all the
memories but basically not having vision
soul so
i guess that's one other thing i took
from this that the
the hex vision was vision soul
and she said she had a piece of the soul
stone but i wasn't sure if that was
true the mind stone mindstone sorry yeah
i wasn't sure if that was correct does
she have a piece of it
or is that just like i think she means
it gave her it gave her her power so
essentially she is a piece of it like
it's like she has the power of the mind
stone in the same way that i guess
captain marvel
um uh has what power stone uh
yeah yeah i think yeah yeah
interesting so then we we i guess we
also saw at the end of the last episode
with the two post-credits scenes
the um scarlet witch and wanda
kind of being separate at this point um
and i've seen tons of speculation about
that i took that to be quite similar to
doctor strange although she is
more powerful than doctor strange as
though she is actively still in control
of scala which they've not split but
what did you guys take that to me
same as you i just took it as her
starting to master her powers and she's
obviously
going through the dark hold and learning
more about what it is to be the scarlet
witch
i i don't know if you want to jump into
this i'll just simply throw it to you
guys
i'm taking what we're seeing with the
way that the show ended potentially
this is almost like an anakin skywalker
story where
i i think she's going to become a
villain i i do i think
i think she was a villain yeah yeah yeah
like when people are like who is the
villain who is the villain i'm like it's
literally her
it's been her she's quite literally the
villain doing this and they kind of like
had to spell it out for people
like yeah she trapped she's no better
she actually trapped these people she
kept them from their families
she harmed them she created so
she tortured them yes there was that
woman that was like crying as she's like
you know do
like repeating the thing but she has now
created trauma
as a trauma survivor she has now created
trauma in these people's lives that they
will have
forever that's true and they said like
we see your nightmares as aside from the
fact that they
went through this period of their lives
that they will carry with them i i find
trauma
as a trauma survivor and someone who
studied trauma so much
um i find trouble like the what hurt
people hurt people or whatever like i
always find that very
fascinating in storytelling um
especially in superhero films because
they don't always get to tackle that and
so she
in my mind is a villain already and i
think that's okay
i'm not saying she's like you know
should die
or anything like that i just think it's
okay to think sometimes that your heroes
can what can also
be i think vigilante and villain is
like the same coin so i always think of
that with these superhero things of
people who take the law into their own
hands
are a villain in other people's eyes and
i think
there are so many good characters who
walk the line back and forth too i mean
like i think like
now that we're 25 projects into this
universe like i i hope they do play more
with like some of the people we think of
as
heroes who we've seen as the avengers
fighting side by side
maybe he did [ __ ] something up or do
something bad or or you know like
wanda had this traumatic experience like
i think the question remains in reality
like will disney let her be a villain
moving forward or is it going to be like
the first act of one movie and then she
has a change of heart
i i hope not i i really what you're
saying i really hope
they take that bold step with her where
the whole point of the multiverse of
madness is her
literally breaking reality and doctor
strange
you know trying to stop her maybe you
you see there's there's an
another villain in there that maybe
becomes a bigger big bad down the road
but
let her be the villain of the multiverse
of madness i i
as if you really go back and look at
wanda's history in the mcu
it's never been good everyone has always
feared her
the entire time she's never had a moment
of redemption where people
saw her as the hero she's always been
feared like
again going back to to um civil war when
she's on the raft
she's literally locked with the collar
on and changed and depressed and
we go from that to her getting out and
then the love of her life gets killed
twice right in front of her so it's like
yeah i think she might snap how many
times can vision die in front of us
like oh god probably happen again i
think i think you're exactly right paris
like like she was you know they were
basically villains for the first half of
age of ultron um
yeah and in civil war like what happens
in lagos basically starts
everything about the sokovia accords i
mean um yeah
it is like the fascinating thing to me
looking at
uh to kind of what daniel was talking
about earlier about how much the
schedule has shifted
like we know doctor strange is in
spider-man which is this year which is
like
way before multiverse and madness now
and so it's going to be interesting like
elizabeth olsen is not confirmed to mean
spider-man but
spider-man also even far from home takes
place
after one division because wanda vision
you know is happening in that period
right you know monica comes back which
is happening during end game and this is
like a few weeks after
far from home like they redid the whole
school year they it was safe enough to
fly to italy
like i mean you have to assume that's
like months or even a year later
um yeah they said it was eight months
after after yeah
so i think like like j jones and james
said at the end of far from home
could be a multiverse thing that we just
haven't seen the fallout of westview yet
like there's so many cool cards in play
that kind of to your point alana like i
i
completely agree a self-contained grief
story is amazing and
you know on some level i totally agree
with you and would love to see what that
looks like
but also i do think there's a lot of
cards in play for the rest of the mcu
now to see how this is going to cascade
through like
jesus there are so many things left even
this year if they don't delay everything
like it's completely insane like it's
eternals it's uh shang chi it's
spiderman it's loki
it's hawkeye it's miss marvel like
there's so
much so uh it'll be really fascinating
to see how this all comes into play
yeah i wasn't sure exactly how many
things surely someone has made like a
tidy infographic
somewhere of all the stuff that's coming
out what are we in phase four well it's
it's
we're in phase four and one thing just
to go full mcu nerd that i think is
really interesting
is that you know because of like pietro
because of these spider-man rumors and
the title of doctor strange
i think everyone is under the assumption
that the big thing
in phase four is going to be the
multiverse but if you look at like that
schedule of what's coming and you look
at how this show
really gave uh wanda the title scarlet
witch i think it's going to be more
about
titles and mantles you know like falcon
the winter soldier is going to be who is
captain america now
and like looking further hawkeye is
clint barton passing it to kate bishop
and thor is jane foster thor and regular
thor and you know there's so many black
panther two is gonna have to figure out
who the new black panther is
uh yeah black widow is florence pew is
probably gonna take up the mantle like
there's so much of that that i feel like
before they can get to
three spider-man and alfred molina and
all that [ __ ] they
kind of have to rebuild because they
lost tony stark they lost steve rogers
you know and so
it'll be interesting if there's a slower
burn than people think well
you know another subplot not to detract
too far from wanda vision that's also
part of what black widow
and falcon in the winter soldier is
about thunderbolt ross is creating the
thunderbolts
you know on under you know under the
hood while all this is going on so
that's something else they're slow
burning
introducing as well so at some point
that's going to be a big reveal
not to mention like uh we brought up
before she-hulk that's
they're bringing back the abomination um
you got to figure thunderbolt ross is
going to be involved in that as well
potentially red hulk so there's
definitely a lot of moving part mcu
parts that are happening and yeah kovit
has kind of screwed
things up but again i would say
selfishly
going back to back to your point we all
think it's about the multiverse
i i would love that the big bad everyone
thinking oh it's going to be king the
conqueror
what if it is scarlet witch what if
scarlet witch is affecting
everything across the mcu and then
everything has to build up to stop her
in the end that's a bit i'd love that
amazing yeah i don't know if disney
would do it though um but one thing
that's on the schedule here is
is called what if what is what if oh
yeah
animated in a way that's a multiverse
because these are things
and yes that is well what if captain
or what was like one with uh black
panther what if um
uh t'challa was star-lord as an example
right
what if peggy carter got the super
soldier serum instead of
steve rogers things like that i mean
they
they announced it as though it is just a
fun and like they got the voices back
and it's just a fun animated diversion
of what if
but like saying what if this many times
is weird but what if
it is actually like a backdoor into
multiverse stuff paris i think that's a
really cool idea like like
maybe that is part of how they'll
explain i feel like it almost definitely
will be
like yeah based on that description yeah
i mean it's super exciting and i always
want to say like the way that
the mcu has managed to have this many
characters and this many stories and
this many films and now this many tv
shows
on this timeline like especially with
endgame all leading to this one thing
where if you go back and you figure out
where each of the pieces of the gauntlet
are
or each of the stones are like it's wild
how
well-tracked it is there are some
loopholes in there but it's
amazing to have done that and then like
retroactively have backstories for some
characters
the only other people who did it were
wu-tang i've been saying that for a long
time
it's it's the mcu and it's wu-tang
nobody else has ever pulled it off
it's super impressive and i feel like
you know there's so many opportunities
for it to get messy but
yeah a lot of stuff to be excited about
here i mean what do we think happens to
agatha is that
because i know i know about agatha
having actually read a number of scarlet
witch comet
comics of you know she she effectively
trained her like she is this witch who's
existed for like
thousands of thousands of years um and i
thought was a pretty cool character and
is actually more of a mentor in the the
comics that i read obviously even marvel
comics changed their own stories a ton
but uh yeah she's definitely really
present in
um the scarlet witch's life and and
across comics in general so
i was wondering like are they is this
all they were using her for because
she's such a good actress too
i would imagine if whatever their plans
were before
uh all this went down they've definitely
changed there's no way they're letting
go
you think so not come back in the mcu i
would
i would love to see her ultimately
become
almost a loki level pest just throughout
the ncu where
she's showing up causing havoc
throughout you know different stories
story lines with different characters
not just focused on scarlet witch that
that's the hope anyways because again
she was she was phenomenal she's so good
in that series so
she definitely needs to be used again
and they send up pretty well it's like
i'll know where to find you like they
could
you know how cool will it be 11 movies
from now when wanda like goes to west
view and you know like they could
totally make a cool moment out of that
so
i feel like sorry go ahead no no good
i was gonna say i feel like she'll pop
up in the other shows or like in another
show
or something as far as her actually
being in the films
i feel like it would probably be a cameo
i don't know if she would have like um
but i agree i think catherine han is
like making a huge
comeback right now and she's been around
she's been everything she's been in so
many things but i think like
she just people really latched on to her
and when that happens i definitely think
as an actor it helps your
helps you like move into some of the
like okay you saw everyone i was the
number one trending
see the tweet for two to three weeks
yeah that does happen
and so then their agents are like all
right what else can we get her and and
they're not stupid marvel's not stupid
so i think there are a lot of people in
chat saying that maybe uh
doctor strange two would be a thing that
would be fitting for her to show up in
and i feel like that would make sense
but i don't know if that's like in the
time yeah
at this point i mean i think again it's
like it's whatever the next
wanda moment is going to be like you
could totally see like wanted needs to
learn
like if they do want to take that mental
relationship you know if it's true that
doctor strange is going to be mentoring
peter through whatever the hell is
happening in spider-man
then like wanda might need a mentor
that's probably not also going to be
doctor strange especially if she's the
antagonist so
there's all kinds of cool stuff they
could do if she does like go to westview
grab agnes turn it back into agatha or
release her mind hold on her whatever
and then uh
you could totally see cool stuff um
marvel writers are
smarter than my shitty theories are
gonna be but i'm sure they can find a
really cool way to bring her back
yeah i mean it was it was almost like um
a cause for suspicion when they cast her
is just like
a sidekick because it's like we know how
good she is like she's got to be
something more than just this even
though she was killing that role top to
bottom like it was so much fun and i
feel like i i still like really love kat
dennings in this universe as well
like i'm such a fan of that role too
that she keeps showing up and they keep
reusing
her like i i i think she brings like
this really nice charm that i feel like
she's now just
kind of a part of the the bigger picture
too but i don't know where that leads
out
that was the only kovid probably
casualty i noticed in the um
finale was that like captains is in one
she's one line through the windshield of
a car with no other characters around
and it's like
they surely had to like have her film
that and green screened it in it was
like
that was a weird way to say goodbye to
that character who i totally agree was
like
her and jimmy wu were like such an
awesome part of that series woven in and
then in the end she had
literally like four seconds in the
finale so i do have to wonder if that's
another like weird
problem probably it's it's a bummer it's
hard to make stuff during curved turns
out
i feel like we all experienced that
firsthand oh yeah yeah
one line that is pretty brutal but i
agree they were they were both awesome
like a lot of characters in here that i
really liked and i think the
the setup for uh captain marvel 2 is
something that is way out of my depth
that i don't understand so like
it was her mom that was friends with
carol
is that correct and the first one okay
cause i remember that
um so then she is now going to be
akin to a captain marvel like what is
the the suggestion of power there
because she's clearly got something but
i don't know what it what it ties into
yeah yeah i'm not a a huge you know
guru or anything on photon or spectrum
because she's gone had various aliases
in the
in the marvel comics she was even
captain marvel before carol danvers i
guess
at one point but it sounds like her
power level is pretty high
um it'll be curious to see if they do
that
in captain marvel 2 if she's an equal
with carol or whatever
i've always thought not to derail too
much into captain marvel i always
thought
they overpowered captain marvel like she
was kind of the
it was the superman complex with her so
it was interesting how they
dealt with that in avengers end game so
i do wonder
what they plan to do with captain marvel
2 and how that because clearly
they were setting it up that monica's
not necessarily happy
with carol danvers yeah for whatever
reason maybe she thinks she gave her mom
cancer
or because she left and never came back
we don't know but obviously that's
that's something they're building
towards um when that movie comes out you
just made me remember that opening
of like the that she had snapped when
her mom was in hospital and like the
finding out that her mom had died three
years prior
man that stuff's rough like dude she was
amazing shanna paris was amazing yeah
yeah i'm so excited to see more of her
and yeah captain marvel too
like nina costa's directing it like that
that could be incredible i really
um the first one was like i actually
mostly really liked it
um maybe other than the i'm just a girl
fight scene
near the end but i i actually really
like enjoyed uh the vast majority of
captain marvel um
so i'm that's another really interesting
one i know like
nothing about captain marvel is um is
moniker and beau or sorry maria rambo
that's all
from the comics right their relationship
or was that so just a way of introducing
monica okay i
i believe that's in the comm again i'm
like you i i'm sorry yeah french i don't
i don't know
cool yeah i mean again chat saying she's
basically pure energy old light
so that seems pretty captain marvelous
and i've always felt like the way that
they deal with carol is by just having
her be in space
because the minute she shows up for
earth conflicts you're like well it's
done then in it
i think what's the [ __ ] point and we
dealt with that so i feel like now they
have two characters that are like that
but then scarlet witch has also always
been
that powerful so if it's a scarlet witch
versus those two that is
way more interesting like things can get
pretty messy there then they just got to
throw sentry in there
and we've got pure chaos but i can't see
them bringing century to the mcu
um as the only person who likes sentry
on the planet
he's he's way too powerful but very
exciting stuff
um i to just dial it way back to one
division i'm just gonna ask a really
simple question of like
of each of you of the things that we
haven't spoken about what was everyone's
favorite thing about the show um i guess
danny do you want to go first what was
your favorite thing about it
yeah i mean i personally loved how slow
like
quote unquote slow i didn't think it was
slow but i loved again like the risks
and doing it in different i thought they
nailed the the um decades perfectly
especially the otts one it reminded me
so much of like lizzie mcguire
meets like there was also like modern
family the office
like it was very nods you know to that
they nailed that super well
and honestly they could have lived there
longer for me
i could have lived in the bewitch like
had a couple of extra episodes like that
um because i don't need everything to be
super high stakes personally the movies
are the most highest stakes like people
are literally half the world died
and so i don't need these disney plus
shows to
feel the same they shouldn't feel the
same because why have them then um
and so this actually felt like a comic
comics are really corny and goofy
comic book dialogue is super corny
uh if you're like that that lion barney
go read a comic
go read these original comics when she
came out um
those bubbles are very corny um but i
love them and so it felt like a comic
sometimes in these comics nothing really
happened it's like a
dragon ball z episode like nothing
really happened hundreds of episodes
and like yeah yes
also i wanted to say something that is
dbz's like it's tattooed on me and like
something that they do that also i would
love it if the mcu didn't do
is not having death mean something i
feel like death
has to mean something or else these when
when
everyone was getting snapped um i was
like this is not because i think
t'challa went
too and i was like oh this doesn't mean
anything this guy has a
a a three picture deal or whatever um
which obviously has now changed uh with
chadwick passing
but when i saw that and same with um
peter parker
love you also a three picture deal so i
was like
it has to death has to mean something or
these scenes just don't
hold the same weight uh maybe i'm the
only one that feels that way
but i feel the same way in dbz someone
dies like oh they're just gonna get wish
back so i think that there needs to be
with vision i actually wanted him to
die i want some of these other people
like you said it's going to be passing
on the mantel
which we need we're going to be seeing
new younger
people taking over these spaces but i
also think like
they can't ever bring tony stark back i
hope
um all like you know who knows
but um i love and i adore these
characters and as much as we love and
adore them i think that their
them passing on means something in that
world to those characters that are being
left behind and if you just keep
bringing them back then it just doesn't
mean as much to us
personally it's such a problem in the
comics such a problem like it's
a problem with everyone that is true
anime
like we get it and like us obviously
but it's fans also being upset like no
you killed my favorite character
you know where's game of thrones some of
them gone that first season
god i'm sorry i don't care if you loved
him he's gone and so
i think that that has to happen more um
as much as it
sucks fully in real life
anyways i think i always joke and say
death has to mean something but death
has to mean
something especially the show about
grief like
like
yeah if they just replace vision
entirely with with white vision or
vision
as they're calling them i feel like
that's going to be weird like there has
to be a conflict there of them like
not having that same bond but i mean
it's confusing because they could in
theory if he's just the same parts with
the same memories they could have the
exact same relationship but i feel like
that would be like
such a disservice to everything that
they had wanted to go through
and the way that she learned through
that process it would be terrible
so have death mean something i strongly
agree thank you dragon ball z
let people die which it literally
doesn't
and it's my favorite show so i'm a
hypocrite
um andrew i'll ask you the same question
what was your your favorite thing about
it
uh definitely hayward like what a
getting um
um no i honestly for me like uh
it was those i mean like my favorite
moment from the series
was uh the very very very final like
goodbye
for wanted a vision because like this is
a character like we see her parents die
we've seen her brother die we saw vision
die the first time and she's
never gotten closure ever like it's
always been this this tragic moment and
like this was certainly still a tragic
moment but i just love
a moment where she gets to say goodbye
and like i was like a mess during that
moment because like what a like
i don't know i just thought that was
such a powerful way to kind of uh
not really like tightly wrap up the end
of this series certainly but just to to
make it
mean something um and to let her maybe
start the process of moving on
maybe by being an awful villain but at
least still moving on uh
so i that was my favorite moment overall
i do think though um
maybe cheating a little bit but to what
paris said at the beginning like
or actually might have been danny said
at the beginning uh the weekly format
like thank god for that in my opinion
because like i you know like mandalorian
obviously did it too
and there was still some guesswork but
this reminded me of when lost was airing
like just like
the nerdy deep dives every week and the
the theorizing and stuff and
you know i think unfortunately some
people got so deep into it and were so
ready for mephisto that maybe it led to
them feeling disappointed
but i still just loved being a part of
it and feeling like it was this
kind of eight-week conversation it was
um it was really really cool and i
i totally agree that you don't get that
when it's like stranger things is out
and you finish it in like
one night and then that's the end of the
stranger things conversation it was less
of like a yeah a
conversation around you can't have a
podcast like this where i can know that
everyone in theory
has watched it by friday um the only
thing is if someone watched it midnight
thursday or did they watch it friday
night
that's my only like did you stay up much
at all but that's it
it is really nice and i feel like that's
like something that's always so good
about video game releases and people
getting them at the same time is like
you get to talk about stuff at the same
time
binging totally ruins a little bit of
that culture i strongly agree and i also
think like
just the digestion of the show like
being as weird as it is like i think it
was paris who touched on this it's like
just giving it more time to marinate and
like let you think about pieces of it
did let people speculate a lot but it's
also just like made points hit harder
and
i don't know made me fonder of it um
overall
uh paris same question to you what was
your your absolute favorite thing
yeah for me it was just overall being
able to take
two characters really even four if you
want to bring in jimmy wu and darcy but
taking two characters like wanda
and vision that were on the b team minor
characters in the
scope of the mcu and giving them
their moment giving them time to flesh
those characters out
actually learn about those characters
what are their motivations what are
their sadness you know
all of that wrapped up into one and they
did it in a unique way
with the format of of going through the
decades of the sitcoms
which i thought was great because it had
a a very good nostalgia feel to it as
well
but that coupled with the weekly format
really took me back to like the
mid-2000s with lost
for me because to me that was one of the
first shows
where it was that true water cooler
moment every week
where we had to talk about i got to talk
about it so come come on let's hop on
the clubhouse or something we got to
talk about it
and we had that even the fact that all
the speculation went up not
really going anywhere it was fun to do
it it was fun to wonder
oh my god did you see that easter egg of
the grim reaper
oh no the the assistant art director
in a tweet had wonder man in the
background what does that mean it's like
we had all this stuff going on and it
was fun i had
fun the last nine weeks you know talking
about this show
and i think ultimately that's the point
right you want to have fun with this
stuff we know it'll carry on into the
bigger mcu that'll be
branches that that that'll continue with
this obviously but as a self-contained
series
i think wandavision did its job it
entertained us
you know for a few weeks we got to
speculate it brought people together
we're literally doing this show right
now because of that show so
i thought it was great and then to flip
it on
its head completely when i asked
everyone's least favorite thing about it
what did you not like about it uh i
guess we'll start with you again danny
if that's okay
throw you right in there i know
i was like what did i i can't think oh i
guess just more time
for monica you know um and i know it's
setting her up
for for something huge but i think that
was like one of the main complaints
especially in the finale and so i think
that that is uh
we'll get to see that but i think see
more um
yeah and like we said a lot of the other
characters who are all heavy hitters
and so that's hard in an ensemble cast
in a half hour
that's very difficult to get to
everybody uh and
like moving the plot along and getting
to villains and all that so
i feel like um i agree just getting to
see more of them and maybe we will
in the other shows but yeah i would just
say more time with
our other our other characters as well
andrew yeah i mean i agree with that
i think for me it's hard because um
like alana i agree with the what you
were saying with like the build-up to
the villains
in the finale and like for a minute
watching the finale when it was just
like
man of steel vision v vision yeah i was
disappointed concerned
um yeah but well but i i feel like it
went on for maybe just
a hair too long but i did love how they
subverted it like i the ship of theseus
moment might be my favorite
you know vision scene yeah in the show
really because i feel like that's so
and and the the wanda twist with the
runes in the fight with agatha like like
they paid off well so those don't really
stick with me as like a super negative
from the finale but what does
joking earlier but like hayward and the
military stuff
was just so it was the one element and i
it didn't bother me that much throughout
but really bothered me in the end
just how like come on like we just don't
need like that moment of um
shooting at the kids and the military
trucks pulling up just felt like
i understand why moments like that are
there and god knows we've seen enough of
them
in movies like this but that to me was
the moment i was like ugh like that was
like the one time the finale i just like
i
because again it takes away stuff like a
moment for monica you know like
and monica had that like two seconds of
saving the kids but like i would have
much rather had a character driven
like extend the conversation about grief
that she has with wanda about losing her
mother yeah like
i would much rather have four extra
minutes of that than have like
hayward actually with hand getting mad
because
it's just i don't know that that was my
the misstep for me was um
so what did he actually get arrested for
didn't quite end
shooting at kids i guess yeah
or i think maybe it was i mean he
effectively
if if he was keeping project cataract or
whatever that under wraps i guess maybe
he effectively
stole the vision i mean i guess maybe
what they're going for is that he
effectively
commandeered a weapon to use it for a
personal agenda and then he was
he basically confessed to jimmy wu that
he was going to cover it up later
so i i guess maybe it's that yeah i like
wasn't entirely clear i was like
get rid of him though like i don't i
don't even need you to explain yes get
that guy out of here
i agree uh how about you paris what did
you not like
dottie because i had such high
expectations for dottie because
they what was that episode two they set
it up that she was the key to everything
in west view and she they she didn't
show up when uh on
you know the when they had all the
pictures of everyone and they were
identifying them they even had agatha up
there even though they didn't identify
who she was
the fact that they kept keeping dottie
off screen i go
oh my god she's got to be something
right there's got to be something with
her actually
i have a tie it's dottie and the rabbit
because the rabbit turned out to be
nothing too oh my god i forgot about the
rap
i was just yeah it was just a
disappointment that
those two things didn't pay off in some
way at least
leading towards something they were just
oh she was just a regular
person who just you know wanted that
wanda was mind controlling and she was
like please just let me talk to my
daughter that's all
i mean ultimately that was it there was
nothing else to the character
yeah she kind of just disappeared it
would have been funny would you like a
third
end credit scene it's like the bunny and
then it like transforms into a person
and they're like naked and like
scratching themselves
just to have it have like someone huge
yeah like chris hemsworth
yeah like do you feel like they uh oh go
ahead
go ahead well you can say the you know
the the stuff about setting up and and
if that makes it disappointing like i
think um
you know marvel has kind of trained us
to do that
and so i get why like in a normal show
if you see like a rabbit
you're probably not gonna expect from it
or like the nosy neighbor
um i do the thing about dottie being the
key
was at least it was agnes who said it
who ended up
you know being deceiving the whole time
anyway so it's like that one didn't
quite get me as hard but i do think that
like the people who are disappointed
especially with pietro and and some of
the the aerospace engineer
people thought was setting up reed
richards and mephisto everyone was so
convinced the devil's in the details
means mephisto's gonna be like
so many people were reading into
everything um and i think part of that
is um you know sort of what we've been
trained to do
yeah because you hear one line about an
infinity stone and then eight movies
later it's like the most important thing
you could possibly cover um but i guess
part of it is like
maybe that isn't what this crew wanted
to do and that is where the burden of
being part of the mcu
becomes really hard i imagine for a show
runner to you know want to have little
red herrings and keep people guessing
knowing they're going to have a weekly
release but also you know
let people feel like there's payoff it's
a crazy balance but the payoff i'm
just going to say again can happen and
does happen
later there are many things that have
paid off over the course of like we'll
go oh my god i saw that like
two movies ago and i knew when they
planted that and so
i do think that that'll happen i think
they can't spill everything
again it's also like not to go back to
television writing this is a half hour
program you just cannot get to
everything
um in that in that allotted time and a
lot of
and all that they wanted to do which was
mainly i think
have this send off or whatever get to
see the behind-the-scenes moment of
wanda envision i think was the most
important thing to them
um and and just doing right by this
character
like like we said wanda has not gotten
to have a main storyline
a lot of the time she's not the a the a
team the a-list celebrity the a
you know whatever and so i think it's
just like finally getting to live with
this woman and see what daily life would
be like with this woman
and her backstory um but i do i do think
some of those will pay off even if it's
frustrating that we don't see them now
i think it might be satisfying to see
them in the future
um and i hope that when people do fan
theories they just
do it for fun you're gonna get like it
should just be
something fun that you're like oh you
know and not so angry
please there's never a reason to write
the show runner they also do not control
as much as you think that they do
uh so yeah and don't get me wrong i'm
happy i would have been
so disappointed if it was like mephisto
is here and he's been like i
i don't think they needed that at all i
think um
i think the one that seems to sting for
people is pietro and i think again
that's yeah that's because of this like
multiverse conversation
it's him there there were two comments
just back to back that i wanted to read
sorry to cut you off that
people just complain about evan peters
in general like um evan peters was
wasted on a dick joke
uh the ralph bona thing with evan peters
was a massive letdown like i do feel
like it makes sense to me that that one
like if i feel like that seems like a
witness protection name it could be
something more than that but i get why
people have already
boner is not a name there's more to that
someone out there is called ralph bona
andrew that is somebody is called down
you just roasted them
i'm sorry i saw and i i'm so stupid i
saw and i was like bonner but i
i really do understand why that one
pissed people off like it's it's a
a choice that was like uh because you're
teasing like that
actor not just the character and then to
have that like dialed back that way even
though i thought he was very funny and a
lot of fun and i love the malcolm in the
middle bit like that was all so cool
like to do that like
that's the one where i'm like i get why
people are annoyed about this one i
understand
yeah it's it was a spicy cheese i do
want to
i do want to take it back a little bit
to the whole overall thing with the
easter eggs and like danny you're saying
potentially
these things pay off down the road yeah
i totally get that we've obviously been
trained since 2008 to look out for this
stuff right
but the way one division was set up
which i think was one of the
the best scenes in the entire series but
then also confirmed
that i i can't realistically expect
a lot of these things to pay off is when
wanda is driving through west view
gets sees the note from the deed from
vision
and she loses it and literally creates
this entire
reality we find out there was no
manipulation happening there was nothing
it was
her grief that created this whole thing
agatha only showed up because she was
like my god who's creating all these
spells i need to go check this out
so she infiltrated it to literally she
was testing wanda
wait how powerful is she what's going on
here i need to understand this so she
literally was pushing wanda
to get to the point where oh my god
she's a scarlet witch
but there was no arterial motive which
as i'm thinking about
why was agatha pushing her to make the
kids unless that was just another test
for creation that's the only other thing
i can think of because again there was
no other motivation
thankfully you just wanted to know if
you could do it other than she was
right right just to see if she could do
it but again that goes to my whole point
so there wasn't like
this stinger where we're like oh
wanda did all this but it was this that
was motivating her
pushing her to do it she's she's
resolved her reason
for creating the hex that's been
resolved in this series there's nothing
other than the fact that she has the
dark hold i guess that
we can take with us from the series to
go okay
this is what's going to lead to doctor
strange too you know what i mean so
that would be my only other little
disappointment here that
i just felt like they had easter eggs in
there for the sake
of having easter eggs because they know
we're trained as an audience to look for
that stuff
but they weren't actually putting
anything behind them that had any weight
that's so crazy is it i i think that's
what i liked about it that's so
interesting i think i was
i felt relief really i felt relief that
they let it just be her grief that
caused it because um
i i i totally hear where you're coming
from and i think you're totally also
right that like
maybe cut one or two of those easter
eggs like knowing that like people are
gonna expect it
but i really i think it might have even
if it had been this incredibly
super hyped moment at the end where like
oh my god actually
ultron in a life model decoy body was
behind it or whatever the hell people
thought
like uh even if it had been that i think
on a re-watch you would have it would
have cheapened like
the eight episodes before that and
especially that episode eight which was
like
probably my favorite overall episode of
the season because it was uh
really brought it back to her and kind
of explained everything before it in a
way that made it believable and made it
made me care about her
oh my god so much more yeah i really
like her now and i feel like i didn't
think about it much previously
i was like i'm a fan now so i think in
the in the long run i think it was
better to to not have those moments but
i do agree with you that those
the the lead-up felt maybe potentially
misleading that we we thought
maybe some of that stuff would be coming
yeah then don't tease them i guess is
kind of the idea
but um yeah like i said i would prefer
that this wasn't there and it was way
way way way smaller you didn't have any
villains except wanda but
i recognize that's just well i mean it
was also the hype of like um
paul bettany ended up joking that uh
there was an actor he couldn't wait to
work with
and it turned out he was joking it was
himself i feel bad for him
yeah you too i totally feel bad yeah
he said it as a joke and like i think
everyone just takes
you got to know where you are man yeah
you know where you are you've been here
a while yeah the thing with that one is
we most of us saw it as a headline and
didn't actually
watch him say it because if you don't
actually watch him say it
you can totally tell this he's it's a
joke you can tell he's not being
serious but seeing it in the printed
work like oh my god
magneto's showing up they got him fast
binge is on the way but yeah
yeah and honestly a lot of those click
bait sides do that i see them do it
constantly to tom holland who i'm also
like this
kid i say like one thing like he'll just
have an off comment it'll be like the
headline yeah not saying like all the
things he's actually giving away but
like he'll just like
you know oh i'd love to work with this
person it's like confirmed so and so in
you know
mcu and so i think a lot of those
articles and publications like bank on
people
for sure or not clicking on it and just
taking the headline and retweeting it
like
true we all contribute to the problem i
think it's not great
um there's a good question from someone
called showia who asks where did vision
go
where did white vision go i don't know
the answer to that question
just flew off somewhere i don't think we
know no
but think to the woods
yeah i'm not sure
but you know really quick speaking on
paul bettany as a whole
how lucky were they when they were
originally bringing all this up to cast
that guy to just be the voice of jarvis
they could have gotten anyone else
that's just a great voice actor but they
went and got this guy who just
seamlessly
went right in from the jarvis into being
vision and
i in that way with the white vision
thing i'm glad
they they did kind of did the star trek
two spock the mccoy remember thing and
kept him around even if it'll be
slightly different because
i think he's been such an asset to the
mcu i mean i think
if if i'm not mistaken he's the only one
left from the original yeah he's he's
he's the
only one left right samuel jackson i
guess oh yeah technically yeah but
yeah but it's totally true i mean and
like um
that line that they built into his final
little monologue where he's like i
started as a voice without a body and
then i became
uh oh my god i'm forgetting the whole
thing but that was such a cool line for
that exact reason because it
totally is true that like look how far
he's come
within this world there's people saying
they think that maybe he went to
wakanda to find his old body but i don't
know why
that would be there anymore wasn't that
in the lab and then taken
no that's the body yeah oh yeah they
literally use the same pods
um yeah yeah it is literally the
original body i don't know i guess
we'll find out but yeah yeah i i hope
that they
just make vision a little bit different
like like we've been saying it's like i
hope that he's not exactly the same they
could do that but it also would have
been almost weird if they didn't
resurrect vision in some way because he
is just parts
aside from the stone obviously we know
he can be remade he is he is a robot uh
that you can give memories to and i did
really like that scene and a lot of the
writing i actually felt like it was
really well written across the board
like really pretty much everyone and
again to those different eras which is
so so so impressive definitely my
favorite thing about it um
we've totally touched on it but love the
exploration of grief across the board
my my big thing is i wish it had been
smaller i wish
wanda really had have been the vision
you didn't have all these extra people
on top of that that i didn't think were
really necessary when it could have been
just like
a woman coming to terms with the grief
and how it was negatively impacting
everyone else around her while she was
like
massively hurting tons of people because
she's so goddamn powerful
definitely not saying that it shouldn't
have led into the mcu but like did we
need
that many villains is kind of the the
way that i feel about it like
i don't even know if agatha would really
count as a villain in this case but i
i don't think that like having that and
then he would as well like and then this
you know dragon ball esque superman
fight at the end is like something that
really like
was closure to me for this story about
someone losing someone
uh quite as much as the scene where you
know you see the hex coming in and she's
like holding his face i was like damn
like that's that's the climactic ending
that i i really wanted and i probably
would have liked more of that but
overall i feel like it was really fun it
was a really fun show to watch it was
really creative they did things that
i feel like marvel and disney both don't
do that often
i've never seen anything like it before
and i hope that we get more creative
stuff because their response to this
seems to have been really positive and i
know it was the
i'm not sure if it's across the board
but for them at least their most popular
show of the last 12 months
a lot of people watched it so hopefully
that encourages more studios to get more
creative this is my closing thought
than anyone else we are at an hour
exactly wow that's amazing
i'll just simply say and and not to
elaborate on it too much but you brought
up the point about agatha
was she really the villain think about
it
she was actually trying to help wanda to
understand her power when she realized
what wanda's power was
she's like you can't handle this i
understand what this
is please give it to me you're an atomic
yeah i will let you stay in this fake
reality with your family
because you because she never monologued
like i'm going to get the chaos magic
and destroy the universe she never said
that so
we honestly don't know what she would
have done if she got wanda's power
um i think first of all she killed
sparky paris well that's what i was
gonna say
good point that was pretty good yeah
[ __ ] up
it's hard to come back from that
actually but no i don't feel like she
was really a villain like
um she the very end of that fight right
after the rune reveal there is a moment
where she tries to use her power and
doesn't have it
and she's like she had she had lied to
wanda she said like
i'll fix the flaws in your spell if you
give me your power
and then at the end of that fight she
was like you can't change this you can't
change a spell after it's been cast yeah
so like
there was a shade of villainy there for
sure but but i hear you like
i do think it's like maybe that would
have been a possible outcome for wanda
that wasn't some villainous so
it's interesting for sure well i was
going to say the fascinating thing about
agatha's
power is she says that she can take it
from the undeserving
so that means that's technically not
very villainous because it means like if
you don't deserve to have your power
which she
that's why she was able to at some point
take some of her power
so that's like a really fascinating
moral complex
interesting so she did take some of her
powers like the hands changing things
she managed to take some of it and then
but the part where she changed her face
and stuff was fake
it was faked by i think one just took it
back i think her
yeah she took it back yes that's it so i
think she became dessert like she
realized right she had to come she had
some
hard truths that she had to come uh in
that episode that allowed her to be able
to reuse her power and that's why i'm
very fascinated by that final scene
then credit scene of her as a scarlet
witch because it's like is she going to
break bad
or not because it did seem like she
learned in the end of that episode that
like i have to let this go
um i you know this is a route like i
have to get out of this fantasy and
actually
confront my grief and live in this world
um and so it seemed like she learned
that's why she got her power back but
also who knows something
she could snap or something could happen
that makes her
that makes that turn man i read that so
differently that's interesting i took
that as
like who the hell is agatha to decide
who's undeserving like thanos thought
half the universe is
undeserving and that's why he wanted to
take them away you know like i i took
that as a full-on
you don't deserve this because i'm a
villain and i think i'm the best and i'm
going to take it so that's
really i i like your interpretation
better truthfully but like as i was
watching it
i i totally read it as her being a
villain that is a
fascinating different way to read that
that line and where wanda ends up and
and i think
that's probably a much more interesting
and fitting
way to read the ending so i actually do
hope that's right
because to me i i saw it as wanda
fully embracing who she is like in other
words agatha was warning her your
destiny
is to destroy the world so juan is like
well let me find out if that's true give
me that dark hold i'm gonna go to the
woods
and read up on this and truly understand
my powers because i think
another key with that is she didn't go
to doctor strange
she she knows who doctor strange is
she's aware of him she easily could have
gone to the sorcerer supreme
please help me understand this no she's
like i'm doing this myself
i don't need anyone's help so that's why
again i lean towards
if she's truly embracing the scarlet
witch scarlet witch is a villain that's
just who she is so
it'll be fascinating to see what they do
uh moving forward with that yeah yeah
and what a cool callback that scene is
too
because it uh it's the same as when
doctor strange astroprojects to learn
yep you know when he's in comfortable
whatever um and it plays the doctor
strange music over that scene too
so you know honestly whether one is an
antagonist or not whether they're gonna
be foils or whether they're gonna be
like be working together it's just like
how cool is it gonna be when they
interact in any capacity because
unless i'm mistaken they haven't
actually had a scene together yet even
though they've been in the same movies
they were in the funeral together and in
game that's right yeah it would be the
only
known interaction that we we that's why
i say we at least know
she knows who who who he is right
because tony stark funeral but
she chose not to go seek him out you
know for any type of guidance
so cool yeah a lot of cool stuff at work
a lot of exciting stuff at work
uh does anyone else have any closing
thoughts
she can't wait for falcon the winter
soldier
that's crazy they just the train keeps
on rolling yeah
yeah i mean they're doing a great job
about putting this stuff um danny did
you have anything else that you wanted
to share
no just i hope that people can have fun
i know that that's such a controversial
thing to say
[Music]
but like i don't know being angry is
addictive turns out
yeah i mean yeah
there's yeah so anyways that's my thing
i felt it was fun yeah yeah it was it
was a super fun time definitely like
i was gonna say to anyone who's not
watched it i would recommend it but i'd
also be like well i now i don't know why
you're here so
you know we just [ __ ] up the whole
show for you so i hope you did watch it
um all right thank you guys for joining
me this is a super fun chat i've like
been trying not to talk to people about
it too much because
like it's cooler when you can do it in
person rather of a text so
i was excited about this and it was nice
to get to do it thank you
thank you i guess thank you uh paris
where can people find you sure you can
find me
at kinda funny and you can find me over
at gamertag radio
and i'm on social media at vicious696
danny i'm at miss danny fernandez it's
ms danifer
[Music]
and just like talking about covid i've
written now on three shows during this
pandemic and i don't think
one of them was before the pandemic and
i don't
it hasn't even filmed so i don't even
know
when things really got moved back y'all
like i
really got moved
so follow me so i can show you all the
shows i've written on in 2023
2024 and they come out eventually i feel
i have nothing to show i've talked to my
show runners and they feel the same way
i'm like i have nothing to show for the
past two years
of my life being in a writer's room like
i wrote on a show at netflix i wrote a
show at hbo max i sold a show to hbo max
i'm like
none of them exist so
i was wondering for the because because
yeah
so i feel for i know the one division
the she-hulk crew as well i have friends
in the she-hulk room but like
they didn't even get to finish their
room together
they had to because of cove like they
didn't get to have their final like
photo together and all that stuff like
they didn't get to say bye and rap
together
yeah it's just not having launch parties
and stuff too is is
crazy um it's the only time i'll bring
it up the whole podcast is andrew
uh studio released goes to tsushima and
in theory that was during a pandemic
it's a it's pretty pretty wild situation
for the entertainment industry out here
so
appreciative of people who are managing
to make stuff and hey danny we look
forward to seeing the stuff you wrote
it'll happen
eventually look i'm gonna look really
busy three years from now
what's channel time
uh andrew where can people find you
uh yeah i'm garfapp on twitter and yeah
like you mentioned
ghost of sushma available on playstation
4.
it's a good game yeah thank you guys for
joining me we will see you all next time